this is a production of cornell
university
well thank you michael uh for that
introduction and
it's a pleasure to be talking to a group
of
students faculty researchers at cornell
university
actually i was inspired by a professor
from cornell
on the path of entomology that i took
back in 40
some years ago which was david pimentel
and richard ruth who actually were the
ones that started uh
exploring the role of vegetation
adversity on pest dynamics and that's
what basically
uh that that that work provided a theory
for the work that i was doing
with small farmers that were
inter-cropping corn and beans and
we noticed that there were lower
populations of pests in the
inter-cropping systems and in the
monocultures
and um and then pimentel and richard
ruth were the ones that provided
the theoretical background and framework
that i used
and many many many other people i used
i also wanted to say that uh that
i'm now retired but um and i'm
farming but i'm also i'm continuing some
interest that i had many many years ago
when i was a young
guy in chile uh which was music i had a
rock band
and uh and we composed songs that we put
in the
in the youtube once in a while uh
although we're all dispersed
some are in spain in germany and austria
and chile and i'm here in colombia now
we can do it with the technology so
there's a link
in the uh in in the uh
chat session where you can if you want
to listen to the song
it's in spanish but it has some english
subtitles and it's called when i look at
the world
okay so i'm going to start sharing the
screen then
to to address the topic that that i'm
supposed to address today
um basically um what is the role of
agricology
in the reconstruction of a poscovid
agriculture and food system
and um as a ecologist for a long time
we have said that industrial
agricultural systems
have become a major force that are
modifying the biosphere
and they occupy about 80
percent of the 1.5 billion hectares that
are devoted to agriculture
and most of the systems are homogeneous
monocultures
that are advancing at the at the expense
of um
of natural ecosystems and they have
become dominant
ecosystems then and the
the pandemic um long before the pandemic
as
agricologists were we were warning about
the industrial agriculture becoming too
narrow ecologically highly dependent of
of farm inputs extremely vulnerable to
pests and diseases now
and now to climate change and now as
demonstrated by the kovid 19 pandemic
prone to a complete shutdown by a
foreseeable crisis
like never before i think that kovid is
showing how
closely linked human animal and
ecological
health are becoming and in agriculture
it's obvious that
the health of the soil the health of the
plants is linked to the health of people
and the health of the planet
um so industrial farming um
i think one of in the narrative on kovid
right now
i think that there's a lack of analysis
of the root causes of the problem
and industrial hammer farming has a lot
to do with the croponocultures that
cause deforestation
or the way we we do industrial animal
racing
with genetically similar domestic
animals that are confined
and all that um and the chaotic mixing
with wildlife
with animal production have created the
conditions for the spread of the
of this deadly pathogen many many
pathogens in the past
and for example in latin america if we
look at south america
the advance of transgenic soybean
there's about 56
57 million hectares already of this
monocultures that are advancing
at the expense of natural vegetation and
there are some ecologists like wallace
and others that are saying that
you know as this agriculture advances at
the expense of this natural habitats
where there's wildlife coexisting with
thousands of virus species that that
that that could actually potentially
be contagious to to humans
if we destroy these habitats that
contain these populations
they become in touch with domestic
animals and with humans and that's
one way in which these pandemics are
are exacerbated and what we're seeing
is that the the kovid has impacts on
food system on the processing on the
marketing
and on the on the food production but at
the same time
food production and the food system that
that that that that is existing today
the prevalent one is also affecting the
dynamics of kobe 19.
and there's a word that that is in
being done right now by uh paolo titonel
and a group of people
that are that are looking at you know uh
at what level
it is um the copied is affecting food
production
the trading the marketing and the entire
food system and at the production level
definitely we saw disruption of um
and of access to input and output
markets also
um it highlighted the importance of
local farmers and and how
society now is paying more attention to
the rural
areas as places to live and and produce
so one fact that is important to
understand is that despite the
fact that the industrial farming uses 70
to 80 percent of the land
uh uses it injects into an environment
of 5.2 billion pounds of pesticides a
year
using percent of the water um eighty
percent of fossil fuels produces more
than thirty percent of the greenhouse
gases
um only produces thirty percent of the
global food that we eat
actually the ones that produce the food
that we eat are small farmers and this
has been well documented not only by
agricolleges but also fao and other
organizations
so clearly kovid has revealed the
sociological fragility
of our current industrial globalized
food systems
and the effects of the pandemia are
being felt today
in in every way so therefore a
transition to a more socially just
ecologically resilient
localized food systems is urgently
needed
and i think that's one of the main
challenges that kovid is posing
the transformation of these industrial
systems based on monocultures
you know high inputs and that are highly
degrading
that are also causing deforestation to a
more sustainable low input agriculture
is that is much more resilient
much more diversified and agricology
then
emerges as a science that not only takes
the advantage
the advances of modern science that we
as
university people work with ecology the
basic agricultural sciences like soils
and
and entomology in plant pathology social
sciences but also the knowledge of
farmers
in latin america we're blessed to have
thousands
of thousands of traditional farmers some
of them indigenous
farmers and what agricology
intends to do is to is to promote a
dialogue of wisdoms
from which principles emerge that take
different technological forms depending
on the conditions
that you face locally environmental
social
political cultural conditions and what
we're
envision envisioning as a new
agriculture for the future
is an agriculture that has to be
decoupled from fossil fuel dependence
agriculture that have a low
environmental impact that are nature
friendly that don't cause deforestation
uh there is a resilient to climate
change and other shocks
that's that is multifunctional that not
only produces food but produces
ecological services but also keeps
culture
in place because there are thousands of
people that are still
in the rural areas and they want to
remain there and
and they provide a huge cultural service
and they must be also the foundation of
local food systems because
by the year 2030 80 of the world
population is going to live in cities
cities of more than 10 10 million people
are going to triple clay
triplicate in numbers and each city of
10 million people has to
import about 6 000 tons of food per day
that travels about 1 000 kilometers so
that's totally unsustainable
and that also points out at the
fragility that cities have
that are dependent on on masses massive
amount
of food that has to count from the
outside
so agriculture then shows a different
way forward
by providing principles on how they
design and manage
ecosystems that are based best able to
face and withstand the crisis that are
coming in the future
and the actual the ones that we are
facing right now
because they they they exhibit high
levels of diversity and resilience
therefore this agriculture is much more
able to reduce risk
from many threats and the contributions
of agricology
to um poscobid agriculture we actually
wrote a paper with my wife clara nichols
who is
also an agricologist and teachers at
berkeley that
actually um in the journal of personal
studies
and we we feel that there are four major
areas
in which agricology can contribute the
enriching of nature's metrics
the revitalization of small farms or
pests and agriculture
the alternative the creation of
alternative production systems of
animals
and enhancing urban agriculture so by
doing this
we basically are creating alternative
systems of agronomic production
that are that create healthy animals
that don't use antibiotics therefore
there's an absence of antibiotic
resistance
by restoring the the landscape matrix
we're creating ecological fabrics
where actually the wildlife is contained
with their pathogens
um and then obviously by creating urban
agriculture
and diversified oral systems we create
nutritional diversity and food security
increase also human immunity if you have
access to
antioxidants in vegetables and fruits
which leads to better livelihoods
local food sovereignty and environmental
and human health
so the first approach is to restore what
we call
the landscape matrix basically combining
elements of agricology and ecological
restoration
and in agricology the preferred
landscape pattern is a complex metric of
fragments of forest
separated by a variety of small farms
and in such environments a lot of
research is showing that
that this this systems that are rich in
biodiversity perform services for
agriculture
such as biological control pollination
organic matter decomposition but also
coexisting with wildlife species
so this complex matrix creates
ecological
fire fire breaks as i said that help
contain pathogens from ecological
release
so a metric like this that is
surrounding
farms in guatemala here you can see that
it
that it provides a tremendous amount of
ecological services for this farm
for example when i was studying the
systems in telascala mexico
we know we we looked at the the
surrounding environment that
that around the farms that we were
studying and we found that
all the farmers derived a lot of their
food from the field
the fruits the the borders also were
producing fruits up to
0.64 tons uh which actually con
after the family uh ate all the food and
they
were able to market the rest they
provided 600
that's one-third of the income that came
from from the farm
and then other researchers in in asia
have found that
rice fields that are surrounded by a
complex matrix have more predators
than rice fields that are surrounded by
simple habitats
and therefore that leads to more
predator abundance
less pest incidence less pesticide use
and higher yields and less placebo is
used as very important because there is
a lot of
pesticides that are immunosuppressors
and in the time of kobe 19 that's
something
to consider so there's
many elements of agricultural
restoration
that we use in order not to emphasize
only the uh
design and management of the local farms
but the metric that surround that farm
is quite important and there are many
peasants
organizations in latin america that are
promoting restoration of
uh of landscapes in order to stay in
their territories because
for example this this farming this
farming region in oaxaca written
in the mystica of oaxaca and mexico
farmers had to leave this area because
they had been devastated through
deforestation or
grazing but many farmers chose to stay
and they started the process of of
ecological restoration by
reforesting the top of the mountain with
pinus oaxacans
and local species practices of
soil regeneration and salt conservation
and water harvesting
which led them to the production of food
and allowed
many many people in the community to
stay in the area in colombia
here not too far from where i am in the
via
in the cordillera occidental
in the in the a group of
farmers in in a region called the
yavista in the community of
davio actually um they they decided to
stay in their land but they had to
resolve one main problem which was a
lack of water so they started a process
of
reforestation of the micro watershed
and this allowed for the production of
food
because there was a lot of water not
only for the families the animals but
also production of food but they also
had to transform their their agriculture
their
farming systems from monocultures that
were highly dependent on external inputs
but also degrading soil erosion
promoters
based on arakacha which is a tuber
similar to potato
cassava and others and they started then
promoting uh plants like titonia the
orcifolia as borders
as a production for green manure but
also for example
using ricinos comunis which is a plant
that produces a lot of biomass
as temporal temperate shape but source
of biomass
to end up in in an agroforestry system
today that
has more than 25 species a system that
is highly biodiverse highly productive
highly resilient and the impacts on the
community
was that there was more water more
diversity less dependence on external
inputs
and food sovereignty for the community
and where we have found also
through many researchers in in the
region like caricol jimenez for example
we found that for example the systems
that are more diversified are
less vulnerable to hurricanes and we
have actually we're finishing a paper
from a major project that we conducted
in puerto rico haiti and cuba after the
recent hurricanes
but we're finding the same thing that
eddie colchiomenes found back in
the early 2000s that the farms
are more diversified and more resilient
they less
less much more cultures and famous cuba
you know after ike where um we found
that the farms that were more
diversified
are less vulnerable to climate to
climatic extremes
than monoculture systems so
the the the other part of uh
contribution that every ecology can have
is the optimization of urban agriculture
because the production of fruits
vegetables and eggs
near consumers increases dietary
diversity nutrition and local food
security there's more access to
to healthy food and this is not new
because in the
2005 the undp came out with a report
saying that about 30
of the food consumed in the world major
cities was coming from urban and
agriculture
so eating nutritious plant-based foods
can fortify
people's immune systems and one of the
big examples on
at the national level of the promotion
of urban agriculture was cuba
but after the the collapse of the soviet
bloc one of the problems they had is
that they didn't have any more
fertilizers pesticides
or machinery or gas to bring the food
from the rural areas so they started
promoting
urban agriculture and
actually more than 50 000 hectares that
provide more than 50 percent of the
vegetables consume the
major cities producing meat goat milk
eggs
and generating jobs and one of the
features of these systems
is that they can produce between 15 and
20 kilos per square meter per year of
food
of edible food using ecological
management systems of soil and
crop rotations and inter-cropping
systems and so on in our farming
columbia we're promoting this very
rustic
raised beds many of the soils are very
acid
very rocky so we basically just put on
top of that
a lot of leaf material
and and then we cover it with a compost
and then we produce the crops
in in that system finding that actually
one square meter can provide 20 kilos of
food
that's about 200 tomatoes 36 36 heads of
lettuce
and if each person eats 72 kilos of
vegetables per year
a 10 square meter garden that produces
200 kilos
can satisfy 55 of the annual vegetable
needs of a family of five
now the last contribution i think and
perhaps the most important
is that agriculture can revitalize
peasant agriculture
and there's a lot of evidence a lot of
reports that have come out
that agricology restores the production
capacities of small farmers
and small farmers play a very important
role in latin america but also worldwide
not only because they have a traditional
knowledge
that is very useful uh they keep
much of the agrobiodiversity they
at the world level seven
seven thousand species of crops are in
the hands of most farmers
about two million varieties are also in
the hands of local variety
of farmers which is the basis for the
genetic
the genetic basis for the agriculture of
the future
they produce 50 to 70 of the food
depending on the country
um but using only 25 to 30 percent of
the land
using 30 of the water and 20 of the
fossil fuels
and we have some examples of research
that we did back in the 80s for example
in chile
we set up this small farms of one
half hectare one acre asking the
question is it possible to feed a family
of five
uh with a half actor without using
external inputs
just based on our ecological design all
this has been published but basically
the summary
shows that um this affector after three
years of conversion
after aggregaological management they
were producing so much food that there
was a surplus
after meeting the the family food needs
in protein
in in calories and vitamins etc
which when they were sold actually they
actually
increased the income of the people so
these people not only they didn't have
to buy any food
only oil and rice and sugar everything
else
was was produced on the farm so they
didn't have to spend money on food
they didn't have to spend money on
inputs and then they
they they accessed the surplus they
could sell
uh in cuba there are some very many
examples also small farmers
that are totally self-sufficient but
also they have a surplus for the market
this is the family of casimiro
who you started as a conventional
farming using
growing corn and tobacco but after being
trained in agriculture by the nap
he actually redesigned the farm
with a network of hedgerows and
windbreaks
that play a major role against
hurricanes but also
in terms of producing fruits and wood
and
energy and and dividing the farm in
different
plots that were devoted to different
farming systems
and the most interesting thing of this
farm is that uh
it came to almost zero depends on
external inputs at the beginning it was
highly dependent on external inputs
today the farm functions without inputs
from the outside
is able to produce enough protein per
hectare per year to feed 34 people
with an energy efficiency of 30 that
means they put one kilo calorie and they
get 30 back
industrial agricultures energy
efficiency is about 1.5
and then obviously the product the
creation of alternative
animal production systems where the
animals are not confined
and they're and they're not you know in
in
causing deforestation is to combine
actually
water crops grasses and legumes herbs
with shrubs and trees for animal
nutrition
in the systems the antibiotics are
rarely
used since the animals live outside and
their diet is based on plants grown in
organic
rich soils that's strengthening the
immune system of these animals
and um there are many many many systems
here in colombia
where they have converted these bare
pastures
that are highly susceptible to drought
and so on
that depend on nitrogen fertilizers and
so on
to the systems where you create uh this
forest uh increasing the um
the current capacity from one to animals
to 5.1
per hectare and increasing um milk
production
from 1.7 liters to 1 4.1 per day
so there's less the systems are much
more
um inducive to a better animal health
welfare animal welfare so they're more
productive
and here you can see in this farm in el
latico which is in this in the
in uh in the cauca valley of colombia
where actually you can see that the
production of milk is still around
10 regardless of the irrigation
regimes or i'm sorry the the
precipitation regimes
the the conventional farms i have
monoculture the production goes down
when the drought comes
this system maintains um a resilient
production throughout time
so now the idea is that agriculture has
to be amplified how these
different cases that i have shown you
can be amplified
scaled up and we feel that there are
many avenues one is the creation of what
we call their ecological lighthouses
which are kind of successful farms that
farmers can visit
the revival of traditional farming
systems is another one
so there is a method the pedagogical
method in latin america
called the campesino campesino which is
kind of a
horizontal way mechanism of trans
transfer
of knowledge and experiences between
farmers so
for example in cuba they started in
right after the
the special period with 216
uh farmers that were using agricological
method today there's more than 130 000
and the whole way in which they has been
scaled up is from farmer to farmer
extension systems
where for example a promoter from a
community that knows a particular
practice comes and shares
with other farmers in in a neighboring
community and then each one of these
farmers women and men
become promoters and multiplying having
a multiplying effect
and the case of the mukuna for example
in central america
was a spectacular case of um
of farmer to farmer extension where more
than 45 000 families started growing
in less than a year which is a legume
that
fixes nitrogen and actually in the
mountains
and also the biomass is used as a as a
living mulch
in order to promote the increase the
production of maize and other crops
so many many authors like peter ross and
his group in
ecosystem mexico are this i have been
studying
what are the drivers of the scaling up
of archaeology and they have found that
the existence of a crisis is an
important one
the social organization is very
important you have to have
agriculture socially activating so you
have to have a social milieu
in which agricology is expanded you have
to have practices that are effective
also there are other factors that have
to do with
external allies important pedagogies
mobilizing discourses markets and
policies
so agricology doesn't end
in just changing the farming system to
become more resilient and biodiverse
requires also a major shift from
societies embedded in the market economy
to a greater reliance on alternative
food networks or food
systems reducing the distance between
producers and consumers is important
in order to enhance the accessibility of
healthy food
and using the uh the ideas of vanderplug
which is a very important uh
from the netherlands he says that
basically what we need to create is an
alternative bypass
to the food system that is controlled by
big corporations that determine what
farm
farmers produce what consumers consume
and this bypass is basically local
markets
and also territories that are devoted
and and
to agriculture and alliances between
producers and consumers
so these territorial markets uh that are
usually um
provisioned by by the earth's farms and
are oriented to local and regional
um populations are much more flexible to
respond to changes and perturbations
that are becoming more common and this
multiple commercialization
short circuit channels for food sale and
access
make these territorial markets less
vulnerable to price changes
and collapse of centralized supply
chains and in addition they've
they've reduced the dependence of
producers and consumers from large
corporations that control global
food supply chains so in conclusion
kovit19 has exposed in my opinion the
tragedy of animal factory farming and
endless monocultures
which have led to dramatic losses of
biodiversity has created
unhealthy conditions like obesity and
malnutrition food waste
has also treated
farm workers and this has become very
obvious with it with the kobe 19
um to very bad uh conditions exposing
them to to kobe 19
and undermine the livelihoods of small
farmers
given this reality agricolleges position
itself as a key agricultural
path that can provide rural families
with significant socioeconomic and
environmental benefits
while feeding the urban masses equitably
and sustainably
so i think it's important that we put
food to action
in the hands of small producers peasants
and urban farmers
is the only way to ensure the supply of
fresh food at affordable prices and in
local markets
away from the chains of the capitalist
market this retooling of the
food system is based on short supply
chains
but will require providing small farmers
with land seeds water
equitable markets and so on and we know
the benefits of supporting small farmers
enhances food sovereignty promotes local
economic growth
generate employment reduce poverty and
promotes
promotes diverse diets and better
nutrition
by promoting local access to healthy
healthy food and we as consumers
which we all are uh need to understand
that eating is both an ecological and a
political act then when we
support local farmers instead of huge
corporate
food chains we are creating
socioecological sustainability and
resilience
at the community level and therefore we
have a political role
we need to acquire higher consciousness
about the multiple ecological social
cultural
and economic roles of peasant and small
farm agriculture
and theref and and once we have that
consciousness then we
have to have an active participation of
consumers in creating and strengthening
local food systems by pressuring local
and regional governments to support our
ecological initiatives
so a radical proposal that i have is
that
we need we require profound change
in our food system that will not only uh
imply
breaking the industrial monocultures
with agricology but will also require to
dismantle
the control of multinationals of the
food system
and the neoliberal policies that
maintain such such structure
and this transformational change in
agriculture must be accompanied by a
shift
from a market economy to a solidarity
economy
from fossil fuel to renewable energy and
from big corporations controlling the
food system to cooperatives
perhaps composed by consumers and
producers
such new world should be led by allied
social
urban and rural movements aware that a
return to the way
agriculture was before the pandemics is
not an option
instead we should be actively involved
in turning local farms
into a vital asset for providing food
and promoting autonomy
while consolidating healthy agricultural
territories so what we need is to move
an agricultural system to a system that
is not highly vulnerable
but to a system that has low
vulnerability and resilience to all
kinds of external
events including pandemics with our
ecological principles
we can create systems that have a high
response capacity
given by tight social networks
collective action application
application of agricultural principles
so we're moving from coping to
transforming
many people say climate change or system
change what is it that we need to
address
so with that uh i will leave the group
with a final question
will the copy 19 crisis provide the
impetus to change industrial agriculture
for a transition towards our ecological
based food systems
now that the global food supply change
chains suffer some disarray
is this the opportunity to strengthen
local regional food gaps
to prepare for looming emergencies such
as climate change
and more pandemics gracias thank you
very much
well thank you miguel for a a timely
uh inspiring and informative uh
talk that was it was great i think um
well let some people uh i don't uh i
think
i would look for uh questions in the
chat and call on people i don't know if
i can manage all the
the the hand raising um
but um uh
no i i think the one one aspect i guess
for me to
to lead it off is in
in the thinking about the the systems um
think about the the production practices
i think
i i can visualize going about one of the
things behind the scene zone is my from
my perspective
is can you tell me about how the the
seeds uh
work how they're shared in such as and
how they come about
we in develop work or in like the
organic seed movement
we have a question about what should we
design uh what
what background can we use in this
design
yeah absolutely i mean seeds are the
basis of the whole thing
and farmers share the seeds
unfortunately there's a lot of national
policies
that that are that are somehow
influenced by the upof
that are not allowing farmers to keep
their seeds or exchange their seeds
and but there's a lot of resistance at
the local level in many communities
where the farmers continue with an old
practice of sharing seeds
of networks of seeds because
actually seed diversity is also very
connected to lock into
cultural diversity and vice versa if you
if you get rid of cultural diversity you
get rid of seed diversity immediately at
least in the context of latin america
and rural areas
and as part of the culture is part of
the traditions
women for example give seeds to their
daughters when they get married
so it's there's a long there's a many
many
uh cultural and aspects connected to to
seeds
and there there's also a lot of efforts
uh there's a lot of
seed fairs that occur in uh in many
areas of
peru in mexico here in colombia
where farmers exchange seeds even if you
go to um
to farmers market to buy food you'll
find farmers selling seeds
or seedlings or fruit trees and things
of that nature so
they're very informal networks now
obviously
some of these material can be improved
and i think that participatory methods
of
plant breeding are key and the
involvement of researchers
to make sure that this material that is
being reproduced
is highly adaptable it's free of
diseases all that
all that i think is is important so that
the role of plant breeders
continuously to be fundamental and many
of the tools the new tools that
that you guys use i imagine also can
play an important role
thank you any other questions yes
uh miguel you had spoken toward the end
about actions that need to be
taken to move agricultural systems
toward an agro ecology approach and
one of those was to pressure state
and national governments in the
countries
in which you've worked or are working
how cooperative or non-cooperative
are the governments yeah that's a very
important
question thank you don uh actually in
latin america there are two countries
right now that have a national law of
agriculture
uh brazil and uruguay and this did not
happen because uh
some illuminated politicians said let's
promote agriculture
social movements for years and years and
years were pressuring the
the the local politicians the national
politicians
to a point that their pressure was so
high
that they had to create this loss and so
right now elements of the law are not
being applied in
in brazil as they should because of the
government they have but um they're
there they're legal instruments
that uh that that have many many many
aspects these laws are very very
interesting and i think it would be
interesting for and i know that there
are people in the united states that
have studied the
the national law of agriculture of
brazil
one of the things that it has is the is
for example the provisioning of food
to the schools that has to come from
local farmers 30
of the food that is served in the school
has to come from local farmers can you
imagine that tomorrow
you know cornell i'm sorry ithaca says
all the food that we're gonna eat in the
schools and the university cornell
university and the hospitals has to come
from the small farmers
that would be an incredible instrument
to um
by to revitalize
farmers because they don't have to be
competing in markets they are
they're entering to what we call the
social markets the institutional markets
and and therefore and actually the
government's safe food because
save money because usually um they buy
the food from
big institutions you know and uh that
that brings
kids unhealthy food like pizzas and
hamburgers and things like that
can you imagine food coming organic food
coming from local farmers
that would have an incredible impact
also in public health
so all these things i think are
important that we um
that we take into account and there are
other governments like the colombian
government
and the chilean government that are not
at all interested
that i'm familiar with with this type of
initiatives but eventually
it depends on on the climate you know on
the political climate i think
the united states right now it's i i
would argue that is
ready for changes of the nature and uh
and i know that are
a lot of people working in the social
justice food justice movement
that are thinking about um pressuring
politicians to to make the changes or to
provide the policies
framework for these changes to happen
any other questions for miguel
so uh paul i could read your question if
you would like to read it
uh or if you like to ask it please
unmute
oh yes thank you thank you so much thank
you miguel for your presentation that's
something that i was looking for i have
one question
since you know the
main agriculture the monocrops
agriculture
and the advancing agriculture just
promote
like advanced um
technology like for this kind of
agriculture monoculture how can we the
agriculture could use the advance
of the agriculture so that precision
agriculture
to promote um our ecology systems
well i think uh you know um
i'm aware of the advances of precision
agriculture digital farming
um that the main rationale for that is
to
is to be able to kind of uh model
crop fields and provide crops the
precise amount of the inputs they need
the amount of water the amount of
nitrogen the amount of pesticides the
amount of fungicides and so on
that's something that in agriculture
um we would not be interested in the
sense that um
the rationale of promoting biological
control of pests or
soil soil organic matter regeneration
for nutrient cycling and so on
is different however if farmers
are interested and can afford you know
the
the technologies that you're talking
about i'm not going to hold them
you know um um
prisoners of of of not doing that i
think farmers have the freedom if they
feel that
some elements of precision agriculture
can serve the purpose of
creating more aggregaologically based
systems fine
the problem is that the persons that i
know here in latin america
or where i'm working right now they
cannot afford even a cell phone
and so how can they have access to that
kind of technology
but agriculture is not limited to small
farmers agricology can be used by
large-scale farmers i didn't show
examples of farmers in argentina and
brazil
that are in chile including that are
used in agricultural systems
and but they have two thousand three
thousand hectares now the design of
those farms
um depends are totally different from
the system that i showed
and they regard machinery and they they
could
benefit definitely from precision
agriculture techniques so agriculture is
not
something that will put you in a in in a
jail where you cannot do this it's like
organic farming that you that you cannot
use this you cannot use that
um the issue is that we don't need to
use pesticides when you
when you design the farms uh based on
their ecological principles
because they they reach assist a level
of balance
i'm witnessing this by practice i'm not
talking theory i'm farming here
i started two years ago and i haven't
used one
drop of anything and but i see that the
system
is slowly advancing and
creating a balance we have the presence
of some insects and some diseases
and some soil fertility problems we do
but they become oviated with time
so to answer the question yeah farmers
that that feel that they can use some
precision agriculture techniques or
or models go ahead
some of us uh students in postdocs have
the chance to talk to miguel a little
bit more at 1
30 but i i have bunches of questions on
if anyone else
has one before i pepper him with mine
some of the students would be nice some
of the young people what are they
thinking
i need i need some new ideas
i yes hi
um so i was just wondering um so there
there is a i see like a disconnection
between the fact that there is like a
growing population
but at the same time one of the main
arguments that we hear
is agriculture takes a lot of manpower
because like most of the time you you
will reduce the use of machinery because
machinery
it's almost met for monocropping
so i was wondering if this could be like
the the opportunity to kind of reconnect
the urban and rural population
because with the pen they make a lot and
lots of people have started
started to do a work from home like here
and if i just continue doing like
working from home
maybe i just save one or even two hours
of my
day every day and we're like i could be
living on a farm and spending these two
hours
working in the field or doing whatever
chores that the farmer
tells me what to do and then maybe that
could be an opportunity to kind of
bridge the gap that exists between
there is too much people but we don't
have nobody on the farms to
to to to do the work i was wondering
what you think about this
equation that maybe there's an
opportunity here
well lewis thanks for the question
you see one of the one of the things
um that we need to
debate more about is the fact that
hunger
doesn't have anything to do with food
production
i mean there's hungry people in the
united states it's not because there's
no food
and uh there's some there's poverty
there's lack of access to land there's
other structural issues that explain
hunger
and this discourse this narrative that
we need to increase production because
if we don't
double food production by the year 2050
people are going to go starving
has no basis it's all ideological this
this maltuchum view
is the one that permeated the green
revolution
and uh you know today right now we have
one billion people that are hungry in
the world
is it because there's no food i mean how
much food do we throw away in the united
states per person 115 kilos per person
how much land in the south is being
devoted to grow
biofuels instead of food there are many
issues that we need to address
before we can start even discussing the
question about
food production and population growth um
i think that this is something that has
many
many dimensions and i respect all the
opinions on this but
i i think it has to be debated more than
it has been
uh we just cannot accept the narrative
you know
just like is presented uh by fao or
whoever is promoting these views that we
need to double through to action by the
year 2015.
and then obviously there's no farmers
but
what is the pro how many people are
unemployed right now in the united
states
why don't we put them to grow food
that's
you know a small farm generate one three
times more
jobs than conventional large-scale
monocultures
so why don't we put people to grow food
i mean
it's a respectable job the fact is that
nobody wants to do that
uh only the immigrants and you know
we're used to an agriculture
that in the united states that was based
first on slavery
and then on cheap labor coming from from
other countries
you know it isn't a time that we or the
people of the united states
start farming why not what is it what's
the problem with that
the problem is that access to land if
you want to go farming
in california as a young person you you
cannot do it because you cannot afford
the land and actually the report
go to a report of a website called the
young farmers of america
and the main problem that they mentioned
for them to
the main barrier for them to farm is
access to land
so we have to have policies to provide
the land to people that want to farm
but on that matter i was wondering like
is there
uh is there a possibility that the like
the model
that we see here in north america one
farmer
one farm and then everybody else is
employee or machinery
maybe this is uh like like the nuclear
family this would be like the nuclear
farm maybe the
better system would be like several
families
for one farm and then it becomes like it
can share the cost of acquisition
well this this is a model that existed
in the united states
small farms declined rapidly in about 50
years
and and the land became more and more
concentrated
in the hands of a few because in the us
and in many other countries
the only way to farm is to get bigger
get out
okay so these things need to change and
these are policy
these are changes of the economic system
and this is something that we need to
debate as humanity if we want to survive
are do we want to continue the same way
we we have been
or do we want to change our our economic
system in order to face
the challenges that that as humanity we
are facing
and and i feel that we need to make a
radical change not only in agriculture
in many many aspects of
our industry and our society
thank you very much i really appreciated
your presentation
awesome thanks uh thomas
see your hand is up
thank you i'm unmuted so
thanks for speaking to us there cornell
it's so fun to have you here
so you're talking about uh having a
a policy or program for purchasing local
food and so
new york has actually had that for some
time for the school districts
they have programs where the state helps
support local school districts buying
local food
and so i've been working with one of my
projects in trying to get
more local food that we can produce well
into the school districts in that
program
and one of the
things that's really prevented it from
happening is that
the locals food to make it
be enough profit for the grower
has to be so expensive that it's not
competitive
with the commodity vegetables even with
the subsidy
even with the technical support that's
available from the state
so i wonder whether you've seen any
solutions to that particular
uh obstacle yeah
no definitely i mean if you're going to
compete with economics of scale
there's no way this has to be highly
subsidized
and that's the way that that has been
done in brazil
and we have that subsidy in place
but it's not just subsidy you have to
also train farmers
to um if they use agricology their cost
of production can be reduced up to 50
so these farmers that you're procuring
uh where you're procuring food from are
not necessarily
based on agriculture they're probably
conventional farmers some organic
organic farmers
they're some of the cost of production
are huge yeah actually
i i would say we're doing pretty good on
the bringing agroecological principles
to vegetable production in new york
we're not
we're not bad okay great so one way one
way would be through training and
extension and research to reduce the
production
dramatically which can be achieved and
the second one would be
policies that would uh that that would
basically protect
small farmers because what happens is
that
you can you can be doing what you're
doing but at the same time the local
governor or the regional government is
bringing
food from uh from another region
food that the farmers produce so one of
the things the things that
for example in in brazil they do is that
they don't allow
any imports of food that the local
farmers are producing
so it has many angles and
in california you know that there's many
efforts in the same direction that
you're talking about and some of them
have have not been economically viable
but within
the existing economic system right if we
change the economic system
we change some some of the some of the
pillars
then maybe things could be different
so um definitely bringing it's not easy
theoretically sounds interesting i'm
sure
you appreciate that and but bringing it
to practice
you find all these barriers that you're
talking about but
those barriers are not because the idea
is bad is because the
existing system does not allow is
is is basically biased against what you
want to do
so that's the importance of the
political change the economic change
yeah you cannot promote an alternative
that
that with the same uh system that
that promoted the the other system that
you want to change
you know you you raise an interesting
thing let me ask a more
more difficult question uh here
uh the change in the political system
is fiercely opposed
by the farmers here fiercely opposed
they are
absolutely opposite political camps
so how you know this
this may be an unanswerable question how
does
how do you get a common interest to get
that political change if you have the
two groups
at the opposite hands well you're
talking about the large farmers or small
farmers
if you've talked to farmers around here
the small farmers are not that
politically different from the large
farmers
well are they politically organized yes
all right okay well i don't know how to
change the mentality of farmers uh other
than buying
my example one of the methods that we
use
the lighthouses is that there is a
farmer that is successful
that's definitely producing better
without inputs
uh with very low cost of production
that's a very major
instrument the first is that's the first
instrument for the change
then comes the other conversation that
what this farmer is doing
in addition to changing his farming
system to a more biodiverse system et
cetera et cetera right
it's also a a system that is
the resistance to the to to the the
dominant economic system right
the alternative and that's where the
conversation comes in too
so um that's the way it works in latin
america i mean
network what happens is that the the
reality of
of oppression of small farmers in latin
america is very different from the us
yeah here farmers are highly organized
politically especially those that belong
to the via campesina
and actually in the u.s there are
chapters of the academia
that have a political discourse that
somehow is permeating
very interesting things like for example
black farmers
many farmers are becoming politically
organized and with a with a with a
different political narrative than
you're talking about good thank you for
tackling that one that's not an easy one
so michael unfortunately our time is up
and we want to give professor altieri
a moment for a sip of water before
he meets with the group of students so
uh let's thank professor altieri for
really a fascinating and substantive
talk today thanks so much thank you
appreciate it
i'll take a little break and i'll be
back in a few minutes
thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu